I have no idea how to use this hello
everyone my name is Jimmy I have been
sushi chef for 15 years and a kitchen
manager at captive Japanese restaurant
for five years today I'm going to try
sushi making gathers look very
interesting looks like the bezel very
easy to the sushi just put lies and the
sushi on top these two is too much lies
half rice is good amount let me try this
size is good for sushi it doesn't be I
cut the halfway and then I fresh is
it's sleepy I just take it out like like
this it doesn't work yeah it's not a
shame it has to be covered the front and
the back side I show you how to make the
sushi in s1 a little bit comment sushi
rice make a shine and put on the middle
it is more good right
it's a sushi but this is just like
camping the bicycle I got it I can feel
it it looks like very weird I have to
use my tool
okay this time I put allies and then see
also so this time I'm gonna use the
spiced tuna see you outside this story
is very complicated just have stuff nice
cube it makes the lights cool okay let
me see I put lies press like this scale
sushi yeah these three is very simple
shape is good I used to eat too but this
turn is best to ID would foster it's
funny but I show the easy way a little
bit
plastic just cut a PC and then on top
the sushi rice
every home has the frosted my honest
opinion we have to buy and then we have
how to use but only plastic very simple
and they look more beautiful
[Music]